Speaker 1: Speaking of defendants, Stephen Bannon
is expected today to surrender and be indicted
again over the cash for the border wall scam that
he participated in. This is very interesting. CNN
reporting Steve Bannon is expected to surrender
today to face New York state charges related to
his fundraising effort to build a wall along the
southern U.S. border. Remember, this was the scam
in which when it became clear Trump wasn't going
to build the wall and Mexico wasn't going to pay
for it, etc., etc. Some individuals, including
Bannon, participated in a give us cash and will
build the wall thing and it was a total scam.
The state charges which have been returned in an
indictment, are based on the same conduct Bannon
was charged with by federal prosecutors in 2020.
If this rings a bell, it's because, indeed, Bannon
was already charged federally for this. Then
President Donald Trump pardoned Bannon on those
charges as he was leaving office. Presidential
pardons do not apply to state investigations.
Robert Costello, an attorney for Bannon,
said Wednesday that the former Trump aide is
expected to plead not guilty when he is arraigned.
The Washington Post first reported Bannon's plans
to surrender. And then the other stuff. I mean,
you got you guys probably would understand or
expect all the other stuff. Bannon calls the
charges phony. He says it's partizan. He says it's
political weaponization. He says he's a leading
voice to protect our borders, he says. In fact,
I have not yet begun to fight. They will have to
kill me first, which are certainly fighting words.
There are two sides to this, and I want to remind
you about the to send by by the way, by two
sides. I don't mean there's two sides as to
whether what Bannon did was wrong. That's not what
I mean. There's two aspects to this. First of all,
does the evidence point to Bannon participating
in a fraud? It does. That's why he was indicted
federally and that's why he is now being
indicted at the state level. It is correct.
The evidence points to it. He should not receive
special treatment. If the evidence is there,
you must indict. And that's what's happening. The
second part of this is the victims of the fraud,
the victims of the scam. And we've talked about
this before. Remember that to make an analogy,
after the 2020 election, when Joe Biden won
and was clearly going to become the president
no matter what Donald Trump tried to do, Donald
Trump started fundraising on Send Me Money
and I will do audits and I will do recounts and
I will do legal challenges. And of course, I knew
and many of you knew those were going nowhere.
And if you look at the fine print, a bunch of that
money was being used by Trump to pay off campaign
debt. And there was this rich guy who donated, I
think it was like $250,000. Maybe it was even more
who then sued and said, I got scammed, I should
get my money back because I got scammed by Trump.
And we said at the time, Republicans constantly
talk about buyer beware and you can't have a
nanny state protecting everybody from everything.
So should this guy really be allowed to sue in
this way now? Of course he's allowed, but it
could be dismissed or whatever found against him.
There's a similar similar aspect here in the same
way that Fox News argues no one should seriously
consider the things Tucker says to be literally
true. He's doing entertainment. You could make
the case that no one should really have believed
that Steve Bannon was going to help fundraise
for a privately funded and privately built
wall with Mexico. It's absurd. It doesn't make any
sense. You'd have to be a moron to fall for that.
And so as a result of that, what what sort of
protection, what sort of relief from the state
should the people that were scammed get? I don't
believe that just because you're a Republican, you
deserve to be scammed. I don't believe that. But
there's a real question about this is so absurd
that does it really warrant relief for
the people that were scammed? And if so,
what would that relief be? I don't know the
answer, but I want to hear from you. We'll have
more on this and all of our other stories from
today on The David Pakman Show Instagram. Yes,
you can find our Instagram at The David
Pakman Show. And you can also find some
really wacky hate mail I've gotten in the last
few days on my Instagram. I am David Pakman
on Instagram. That's a period not like
spelling out dot David Pakman find me there.